well Mr President
it's good to see you again my friend
we've met several times over the last
year and each time
we have deepened our nation's
partnership and for the benefit I think
of both our peoples
today is no exception
our nation's relationship is uh has been
a great success story
the alliance formed in war
and has flourished in peace
seemingly every day we've launched new
areas of cooperation
on Cyber strategic Technologies space
democracy
and all the areas that matter most to
our future
because of its core
our alliance is about building a better
future for all of our people
and there's no better example than our
economic relationship and partnership
which as uh is delivering incredible
benefits to both our Nations
through the indo-pacific economic
framework
we're advancing economic growth grounded
in high standards for our workers for
the environment and for communities
throughout the region
we're standing together against economic
influence being leveraged in coercive
ways
and since I took office Korean companies
have invested more than 100 billion
dollars in the United States
driving Innovation and spurring good new
jobs for Americans and Korean workers
our mutual defense treaty
is Ironclad and that includes our
commitment to Extended deterrence
and uh and uh that includes the nuclear
threat and the nuclear deterrent
they're particularly important in the
face of dprk's increased threats and the
blatant violation of U.S sanctions
at the same time we continue to seek
serious and substantial diplomatic
breakthroughs with the dprk
the bolster stability on the peninsula
reduce the threat of proliferation and
address our humanitarian and human
rights concerns for the people of the
dprk
Republic of Korea
and the United States are working
together including through our
trilateral cooperation with Japan
to ensure the future of the indo-pacific
is free
is open prosperous and secure
I want to thank you again Mr President
for your political courage and personal
commitment
to uh through diplomacy with Japan
I've worked in these issues for a long
time and I can tell you it makes an
enormous difference when we all pull
together
I also welcome and support your
administration's a new indo-pacific
strategy it's a strategy that affirms
how aligned our two nations are and our
visions of the region and how similar
they are and today we discussed our work
together on promoting peace and
stability in the Taiwan Straits ensuring
freedom of navigation in the South China
Sea and Beyond excuse me
I also affirmed our shared commitment we
together shared our firm shared
commitment to stand with the people of
Ukraine against Russia's brutal assault
on their freedom their territorial
integrity and democracy and the Republic
of Korea is strong support for Ukraine
is important because Russia's flagrant
Russia's flagrant violation of
international law matters to Nations
everywhere in the world not just in
Europe
when I when it comes right down to it
it's about what you believe
what you stand for
what kind of future you want for your
children and grandchildren and right now
I believe the world's an inflection
point
the choices we make today I believe are
going to determine the direction of our
world and the future of our kids for
decades to come
that's why this partnership is so
important Mr President
because we share the same values
the same vision
and I'd greatly appreciate Mr President
that the Republican Korea co-chaired the
second Summit on democracies last month
and they will host this third Summit up
for democracies
we both understand that our democracies
and our people or our greatest source of
strength and working together and make
our nation stronger and more effective
from tracking the climate crisis and
strengthening our effort to fight it and
strengthening Global health no two
countries are better suited to meet the
challenges ahead than the Republican
Korea and the United States
I want to thank you again Mr President
for your friendship your partnership and
all you've done to help build a future
of shared strength and success
floor is yours Mr President
Biden thank you for your special and
warm Hospitality I am very pleased to be
making a state visit to the United
States during this meaningful year that
marks the 70th anniversary of the rock
U.S Alliance our two countries have
overcome challenges and crises during
the past 70 years based on the deep
roots of freedom and democracy building
a value Alliance that is strong
resilient and sustainable
we are now being threatened by an
unprecedented poly crisis The Rock U.S
Alliance is jointly overcoming this
crisis so also coming from North Korea
as a righteous Alliance that contributes
to world peace and prosperity
we will further expand the depth and
denotation of the rock U.S Global
comprehensive strategic partnership and
marched forward to the future today
president bidened and myself engaged in
constructive dialogue to discuss ways to
materialize this shared Vision the
outcome of our dialogue is well outlined
in the joint statement adopted today
the first key outcome is extended
deterrence sustainable peace on the
Korean Peninsula does not happen
automatically
our two leaders have decided to
significantly strengthen extended
deterrence of our two countries against
North Korea's nuclear and missile
threats so that we can achieve peace
through the superiority of overwhelming
forces and not a false peace based on
the Good Will of the other side
such a willing commitment is captured in
the Washington declaration President
Biden has reaffirmed his Ironclad
commitment to Extended deterrence
towards the Republic of Korea are two
countries have agreed to immediately
bilateral presidential consultations in
the event of North Korea's nuclear
attack and promised to respond swiftly
overwhelmingly and decisively using the
full force of the alliance including
the United States nuclear weapons our
two countries have agreed to establish
a nuclear consultative group to map out
a specific plan to operate the new
extended deterrent system now our two
countries will share information on
nuclear and strategic weapons
operations plans in response to North
Korea's provocations and have regular
consultations on ways to plan and
execute joint operations that combine
Korea state-of-the-art conventional
forces with Us's nuclear capabilities
the results of which will be reported to
the leaders of our two countries on a
regular basis in addition our two
countries have agreed to further Advance
tabletop exercises against a potential
nuclear crisis
in addition deployment of the United
States strategic assets to the Korean
Peninsula will be made constantly and
routinely
President Biden and I will continue to
cooperate to strengthen extended
deterrence between our two countries
based on our historical and concrete
agreement reached during our Summit
second our two leaders have agreed to
further strengthen the Strategic
partnership in Economic Security which
is directly related to the National
economies of our two countries
President Biden and I welcomed the
expansion of our firm's bilateral Mutual
investment in advanced technology
including semiconductors electric
vehicles and batteries
President Biden has said that no special
support and considerations will be
spared for Korean companies investment
and business activities in particular
we have agreed to consult and coordinate
closely so that the U.S inflation
reduction Act and the chips and science
act can further strengthen supply chain
cooperations between the two countries
in advanced technology
foreign
furthermore we plan on ramping up
Partnerships in Cutting Edge technology
we have agreed to establish a dialogue
for Next Generation emerging and core
technology between the U.S National
Security Council and the curry office of
National Security pertaining to chips
batteries biotechnology Quantum science
and other cutting-edge Technologies with
the aim of promoting joint r d and
experts Exchange
Toronto
we have also adopted a separate joint
statement for strengthening cooperation
in the rapidly emerging Quantum Science
and Technology domain
President Biden and I have also agreed
to get the ball rolling on discussions
about expanding our alliance into cyber
and space by applying the mutual defense
treaty in cyberspace and space as well
we have also agreed that the Strategic
cyber security cooperation framework
adopted this time around will serve as
the foundation on which we address cyber
threats together and boost cooperation
in information sharing collection and
Analysis
space is another area that shows great
promise for cooperation between our two
countries
during my time here I was able to visit
the NASA Goddard Space Center President
Biden welcomed the establishment of Casa
and we have agreed to promote
cooperation between Casa and NASA
we have also agreed to accelerate
discussions on reaching a reciprocal
defense procurement agreement which is
equivalent to an FTA in terms of
National Defense meanwhile President
Biden and I have agreed to promote
exchange between the future generations
of our two countries to this end we have
launched the US ROK special exchange
Initiative for youths
in celebration of the 70th anniversary
of the rock us Alliance this year our
two countries plan to invest a total of
60 million dollars to support exchanges
between
2023 youths majoring in stem Humanities
and social sciences
this also includes the largest Fulbright
program to date which will provide
scholarships for 200 students
last but not least President Biden and I
have agreed that South Korea and the
United States as key Partners in
achieving stability and building peace
in the indo-pacific region we'll put our
heads together as we Implement our
indo-pacific strategies to strengthen
our cooperation in addressing Regional
and Global challenges
in particular President Biden expressed
a strong support for efforts made by the
Korean government to normalize Korea
Japan relations
and we have agreed to continue our
efforts in strengthening Korea us Japan
trilateral cooperation furthermore
we reaffirmed that the use of force to
tank the lives of innocent people an
example of which would be Russia's
mutant invasion of Ukraine can in no
circumstances whatsoever be justified in
that sense we agree to continue our
cooperation and efforts alongside the
International Community to support
Ukraine
during this meeting we also discussed
plans
through which our two countries can take
a leadership role in addressing Global
challenges such as climate change
International Development and energy and
food security
[Music]
I am delighted that through today's
meeting we've opened up a new chapter
for the next 70 years of the rock U.S
Alliance I hope President Biden and I
with the support of people in our two
countries
can fully deliver on the blueprint that
we have mapped out today
with the aim of our founded in the
reaffirmation of the value of freedom
and our Universal values
thank you
now we're going to take some questions
the first question from Courtney in Los
Angeles Times
thank you Mr President your top economic
priority has been to build up U.S
domestic Manufacturing in competition
with China
but your rules again against expanding
chip Manufacturing in China is hurting
South Korean companies that rely heavily
on Beijing
are you damaging a key Ally in the
competition with China to help your
domestic politics ahead of the election
and one for president Yoon
there have been concerns since last year
that North Korea will soon be conducting
its seventh nuclear test amid growing
domestic support in your country for
your own nuclear weapons
meanwhile Russia has suggested it could
send its latest weapons to North Korea
if South Korea sends lethal Aid to
Ukraine how do you seek to manage the
North Korea risk amid obligations to
Ukraine and NATO
let me respond to your question first uh
my desire to increase U.S manufacturing
and jobs in America
is not about China
I'm not concerned about China
remember America invented a
semiconductor we invented it we used to
have 40 percent of the market
and we decided that what we're going to
do will pass
I don't know how many decades we decided
that it was going to be cheaper to
export jobs and import product
and long came the pandemic the pandemic
taught us that we used to have as I said
40 of the market just some years ago now
it's down to 10 percent
and again we invented the Supreme we got
so I decided to go out and see what we
could do to increase our cold on the
market once again and so what I did was
I went around the country as well as an
additional passing Egyptian science act
I in fact that these are the countries
around the world
and two significant South Korean
companies decided they were going to
invest billions of dollars in chip
Manufacturing in the United States it
wasn't designed to hurt China it was
designed to so we didn't have to worry
about whether or not we had access to
semiconductors for example during the
pandemic what happened was all of a
sudden everybody started to learn the
phrase supply chain
a year ago no one knew what the hell
everybody was talking about when he said
supply chain but now they all know and
we lost access to these these
semiconductors in which new automobiles
the United States need 30 000 of them
just to build a new automobile
and we didn't have them so we started to
invest here and what happened was when
we encouraged the investment through the
chips and science act and now we have
enormous investment in the United States
over 200 billion dollars in long-term
investment in semiconductors and we're
rebuilding the economy of the United
States with those semiconductors it's
not designed to hurt China the only
thing I did say with regard to China are
certain extremely sophisticated
semiconductors and we have built that
are useful for nuclear and or other
weapon systems those we are not selling
whether we're not exported to China or
anyone else and so that's the context in
which this all occurred in the meantime
we've created thousands of jobs and
bringing back a sense of Pride and
dignity to so many towns in the country
where all of a sudden over the last
three decades we found out that factory
is hired had 600 people shut down
soul of that Community was lost and so I
made sure when the semiconductors are
coming back that they were not just
going to go to the coast they'd be all
over the country and so we have a
significant Field of Dreams and outside
of uh
Ohio outside of Columbus we're in Texas
we're in Arizona anyways all over the
country so it's not viewed to hurt
anyone else we are providing access to
those semiconductors we're not we're a
supply chain you can count on but we are
not we are not going to sit back and be
in a position where we don't have access
to those semiconductors we are not going
to be a place where we're the end of
that line we're for the beginning of it
and uh it's generating significant
economic growth in America and not
hurting anybody and by the way it's
creating jobs in in South Korea it's
creating jobs in South Korea not just
with SK but all anyway with Samsung and
other other Industries
so I think it's a win-win
with regard to your question let me
provide my answer
Korea and the US
based on its Washington declaration our
two countries have agree to strengthen
extended deterrence and the
implementation level is different from
the past
first of all
we have an NCG nuclear consultative
group that has been launched
that will Implement discussions and
actions and we will hold regular
meetings and consultations under NCG we
will share information on Mutual nuclear
assets and intelligence and we will
jointly plan responses
and also jointly plan exercises and
drills and implementation plans
so all of these will be strengthened and
specified under the nuclear consultative
group
we want to
customize our response against North
Korea's nuclear threat based on extended
deterrence and in the process of
achieving this goal
any concerns that Koreans may have
against North Korean weapons will be
relieved I believe
if nuclear weapons are used are two
countries will strengthen our response
in a swift manner
any further questions to me
please
I have two questions
with regard to Extended deterrence
the NCG that has been formed
how will career function under NCG any
kind of
equipped nuclear assets will be in
function and to President Biden
Korea is to maintain the MPT and it is
to strengthen extended to tourists
correct So based on your review do you
think this is enough to guard Korea
against the North Korean nuclear threat
thank you very much
foreign
well let me address your question about
the activities of the NCG we are going
to be sharing information and we are
going to be acting jointly that is the
key
I can't talk to the specifics right now
about what type of information and what
type of specific activities we will be
conducting but however under the nuclear
umbrella our extended deterrence was a
lot lower so right now it's an
unprecedented expansion and
strengthening of the extended deterrent
strategy under the Washington
declaration which will create the NCG
the implementation and the response
at this level has never thus far been
this strong so this is a new level of
extended deterrence much stronger that I
can say with confidence
once I would give you
extended returns
means that we are having more
consultation with whatever actions to be
contemplated or Taken
and we made it really very very clear
any the ROK has repeatedly formed its
confirmness commitment to uh to the
non-proliferation treaty the Washington
declaration is a prudent step three and
fourth extended deterrence and respond
to advancing dprk nuclear threat look
the nuclear attack by North Korea
against the United States or its allies
or partisans our partners is
unacceptable and will result in the end
of whatever regime we're going to take
such an action and it's about
strengthening deterrence in response to
the dprk's escalatory behavior and to
deal on complete consultation and uh you
know the idea that I have absolute
authorities commander-in-chief and the
sole authority to use the nuclear but
you know what the Declaration means is
that we're going to make every effort to
consult with our allies when it's
appropriate if any action was so call
for certainly we've talked about this
and some other things today but the
bottom line here is there's even closer
cooperation closer consultation and uh
and we're not going to be stationing
nuclear weapons on
to them but we will have visits to Ports
visits of nuclear submarines and things
like that we are not walking away from
that
my turn to ask a question
I think the next question is Mary Bruce
ABC
thank you Mr President you recently
launched your re-election campaign
you've said questions about your age are
legitimate and your response is always
just watch me but the country is
watching and recent polling shows that
70 percent of Americans including a
majority of Democrats believe you
shouldn't run again
what do you say to them what do you say
to those Americans who are watching and
aren't convinced you've said you can
beat Trump again do you think you're the
only one
I may not be the only one
I only want to I know him well and I
know the danger he presents to our
democracy and we've been down this road
before and with regard to uh
to age you know and and pulling death I
noticed the polling data I keep hearing
about is that I'm between uh
42 and 46 favorable rating Etc and uh
but everybody running for reelection in
this time has been in the same position
there's nothing new about that you're
making it sound like Biden's really
underwater
and number one number two when the same
polling data asks whether they think
what kind of job I've done it gets
overwhelmingly positive results from 58
thinking everything from the chips act
and all the things we've done you know
we've created like I said we've created
12 million new jobs we created 800 000
manufacturing jobs we have economic
growth moving we're in a situation where
the climate we've conducted more money
and more help in dealing with the
climate crisis in any nation in the
world and so things things are moving
and the reason I'm running again is
there's a job to finish the other thing
is that look you know think about what I
inherited when I got elected I inherited
a nation an overwhelming debt at the
time number one in the hole for the four
years that he was President I inherited
a nation that had a serious law loss of
credibility around the world as America
first and you know the first meeting I
attended the G7 I said America's back
and one of the world leaders looked and
said for how long or how long there's a
great concern about the United States
being able to lead the Free World and
we're doing that again and those same
poles you look at you take a look at the
polls they're saying whether I pull
together NATO and the European Union as
well as Asian Partners I think we have
but there's more to do and uh with
regard to age uh I can't even say I
guess how old I am I can't even say the
number I've done I've done register with
me and uh but the only thing I can say
is that one of the things that people
are going to find out they're going to
see a race and they're going to judge
whether or not I have or don't have it I
respect them taking a hard look at it I
take a hard look at it as well I took a
hard look at it before I decided to run
and I feel good I feel excited about the
prospects and I think we're on the verge
of really turning the corner in a way we
have it in a long time I know you're
tired of him you say we're an inflection
point where we really are what happens
in the next two three four years going
to determine what the next three four
decades look like and I am never been
more optimistic in my life about the
possibilities in the United States
be clear though you just said I know him
well did Donald Trump's decision to run
affect yours would you be running if he
wasn't
yeah I think I still would be running if
he wasn't I do know him well he's not
hard to know as you know you know him
well too
um and uh the question is whether or not
uh look there's just there's more to
finish the job we have an opportunity to
put ourselves in a position where we are
economically and politically secure for
a long time we continue to have and now
you know like we hear him hear me saying
it there's still a contest between
autocracies and democracies
and we're the leading democracy in the
world and it's something I know fair
amount about something I care about and
something that I have found a
willingness and awful lot of our allies
and friends to follow so uh I think that
you know we have to finish the job and
nail it down
you need to repeat the question the mic
was not used we could not interpret
I need to repeat the question
please use the microphone we cannot
provide interpretation if you did not
use the microphone microphone
my apologies thank you
did the recent leaks revealing that the
U.S was spying on South Korea come up at
all in your discussions and did
President Biden provide you any
assurances
with regard to that
we are communicating between our two
countries and we are sharing necessary
information
I believe that investigation is underway
in the United States
so
various and complex variables are always
in play we need time to wait for the
investigation results by the United
States and we plan to continue to
communicate on the matter
will be the last question
foreign
[Music]
s and also investments in businesses
have been some of the outcomes these are
some positives however to each
individual of the public how will this
have a long-term impact what will be the
direct benefits felt and to President
Biden
in celebration of the 70th anniversary
of the rock us Alliance I know that the
atmosphere is really positive however
Korean businesses especially because of
the chipset and the IRA are on edge
what message can you send to the Korean
companies to really make sure and tell
them that this is not something to worry
about
the technology and cooperation between
the ROK and the US and also in partner
Partnerships in Cutting Edge Industries
and Science and Technology it was your
first question so that is about really
strengthening the competitiveness of our
two countries
and it will enhance the productivity and
to create added value High added value
these are the types of products that are
going to be produced and from the
perspective of the public for each
individual in that process they will
reap the benefits wide and comprehensive
that will stem from these industries and
investments in these industries for
example from job creation as well and
above all the future Generations will be
given the determination and will to take
on new challenges and embrace
opportunities in our industry so that
they can continue to prosper and grow
and become more abundant in the future
reassurance is that it's overwhelmingly
interaction
no it is
very much in America's interest that
Korea do well in the Pacific very well
because they are one of our most valued
partners and so I think the combination
of growing democracies in the Democratic
institutions as well as their economies
is overwhelming the benefit of the
United States whether it is in South
Korea or it's in Australia in the Deep
South Pacific and so I think that
there's a reason overwhelming reason
Plus in addition to that we're
increasing the number of student
exchanges access to more information to
between our folks educating our people
as well as we're going to be cooperating
everything from space to technology to
medicine and so there's so many
opportunities we have and I don't think
we at least we don't and I don't think
so far most of the South Korean
companies believe that there's somehow a
a U.S effort to slow them down prevent
their growth or anything like that we'd
like to see them grow and uh and I mean
that sincerely it's overwhelming in the
U.S interest for South Korea to do very
well economically
it's overwhelming in our interest
because it has and lastly you know I
think we underestimate the example that
South Korea sets here you have a nation
that is significant but is not a nation
of two three four hundred thousand
people making the kind of changes it's
making it gives other smaller Nations
hope to believe that if they have
Democratic institutions and commitment
and and an impact on industries that in
fact are The Cutting Edge Industries new
sciences and Technology including Ai and
other things that there's a future for
them and I think that's what this is
about
and so we we View
South Korea's economic growth as a
benefit to the United States as well as
Freedom around the world
thank you all so very much appreciate it
[Applause]
distinguished guests please remain in
your seats until the official
delegations have Departed
they haven't figured out the debt limit
yet
happy to meet with McCarthy but not on
whether or not the debt limit gets
extended more of it that's not
negotiable I noticed they quote Reagan
and they quote they quote Reagan all the
time and they quote Trump both of which
said it's just I'm paraphrasing it would
be an absolute crime to not extend the
debtman foreign